全員笑わせて 目指せ
１００円
ハジモネア～！
し ▶  「始まりました」
いやー、てつやさんしばゆーさん、いよいよやって参りましたね
て ▶ 「 ついにこの企画です」
遂にこの企画がやって参りました
このイロモネア・・・じゃねえや…
このハジモネアでは観客からランダムで３名の方を選びまして、
その３名の中の一人でも笑わせたら、ステージクリアとなる、動画となっております
ジャンルがいくつかありまして、
モノマネ、一発ギャグ、ショートコント、サイレント、モノボケ、
こちらの五つのジャンルになっております
そしてですね、ステージはどれでも自分で好きな順番選べるんですけども
最終ステージのみは、三名中、三名全員を笑わせないと、クリアにはなりません。
「勝利した、暁には？」
１００円を、頂けると
「なんか、文字抜けてないですか？」
大丈夫です
賞金目指して是非ぜひね、お笑い芸人の皆さんには(笑)頑張ってもらいたいと、思っております！
では、今回の挑戦者はこちらの方です。どうぞ！
「よろしくぅ～お願いぃしまぁすぅ～」
よろしくお願いしま～す
いや今見れただけでも幸せですよ、僕は
いやぁ～すごいっすね
「どんな芸を見せてくれるんでしょうかね～」
もう、お笑い芸人、第一人者。虫眼鏡さんでーす！
面白いね！「面白い、面白い」
「あのご飯Ｔシャツ見せて下さい」
スゲー面白いよ
「見てくださいｺﾚ」
おお
「既に面白いですねー」
「○※△？☆＃あ！これ、Ｔシャツ★してね、はーいー」
「観客の皆さん大爆笑」
すごい盛り上がりが凄い、もう今爆笑しちゃいましたよ
「はい◎￥％い静かにしてください、はい、次、進みませんのでね、はい」
≪ 虫眼鏡、１００円目指して笑いを取れぇ≫
なにか、こう意気込みなどはございますか？
そうですね、やっぱりあの～、う”ﾝ”!!　天下の、はじめしゃちょ-さんのチャンネルに出させて頂けると言う事で
なんか普通の人にとって１００万円って大きいじゃないですか？」
１００円
「１００円？」
でわでわ虫眼鏡さん。
「はい」
スタートコールとストップコールをよろしく
お願いシマス
「スタート！」
（ドゥドゥンドゥーン）
（ドゥルンヅゥルドゥル）
「ストップ！」
（ドゥン　ピピピピピ）
はい、というわけでこちらの三名でございます
彼らはまだ、誰になっているのかわかりません
それでは虫眼鏡さん
ファーストステージ、ジャンルは！
(ドゥドゥドゥドゥドゥドゥン)
(ドゥン　トゥトゥン)
(タカターン)
一発ギャグと言うことで！
はい　行きましょう
それでは！虫眼鏡さんのファーストチャレンジです！
スタート！！
ではいきまーす
グーチョキパーでグーチョキパーで
なにつくろ〜なにつくろ〜
右手がグ〜で左手がパ〜で
にぎりっぺ〜にぎりっぺ〜
ぺ
ウン゛ッ
ではいきます。
ジャンケンが派手な人
最初はグ〜
ジャンケンっ
(ズサッッ)
クリア〜〜〜〜〜　(パチパチパチ)
完全に機材やられましたね
というわけでファーストステージクリアおめでとうございます。
(パチパチパチ)
まあ結果からみると
ああそうなんですか。
待ってください。
はじめさん、見てもなかったんですけど。
え、え、、
もうずっとこの辺を見てたんですけど。
セカンドステージやりますか？
やります！
ジャンルのほうを
サイレントで！
次はカメラを壊さないようにお願いします。
3,2,1、どうぞ